and gentlemen will you would spank hood
please so we're all the applause for the
applause
why did you say we'll well your name is
William fun ain't quarter this is my
brand this is my stage name I want you
to call me by my stage name you know
what you're actually right outside you
sir I thought over ladies and gentlemen
spank boys
thank goodness a friend that should call
a brother because I've known you that
long you're from Philadelphia PA Yeah
right what part of Philly from nice town
like class North Philadelphia
hey thanks with that Bang Bang y'all
know what it is okay no need to threaten
T okay I'm caught uh now you were the
guy in college that actually booed
comedian yes so then you start doing
comedy yes
were you ever fearful of running into a
guy like yourself that I like to call
them yeah yeah yeah what why did you why
did you boot comedian what would you
think cuz on college campus I was going
to be the funny guy
so whenever always have my same seat at
every show it would be like you see how
you got these roles right here I'll be
right in the middle dead center right in
the middle right there with my man ever
I think it seemed so you could see me my
hand right and then everybody look at me
if the comedienne donger anybody look at
me like it's that time that I was just
stand up hey by going in and a comedian
got offstage what a dick
uh but mind you at this time I didn't
know the crash and all I do before I was
thinking about how vital every community
should be funny at the end on stage yeah
what sparked the decision to pursue
stand-up comic Kings of Comedy came out
in 2000 I'm number leaving that's it and
a couple people saying when are you
going to get on stage
really yes so was there weird transition
for you when you tried to start doing
comedy with their weird separation from
being the instant funny within the group
and then trying to beat a guy on stage
it was the transition we're gone it's
gonna be a trans because you're funny
people you don't know when you're funny
your friends they know you so they know
you about to be funny but when people
pay and they all know you you got to be
fun you know dance and we're definitely
transition it was definite transitional
I've seen you grow and develop from the
comedian that at one point had three to
five minutes sets those five minutes
that's grew to 10 minutes said so take
this stage to do what you do better on
Friday man I'm having for you next level
brother go do with you
[Applause]
[Music]